but without this Stillness Christ is not
the Stillness is the fundamental
backbone to Christ to God and then from
there is the Wrath against
Injustice and the excitement for New
Earth this is not rocket science it is
so simple it's already already there
it's already listening to this voice
what is listening to the voice is
stillness it's already Stillness
listening to this voice you just believe
it to be a separate self but it's not
it's Stillness it's the entire universe
listening to this voice and then from
that Stillness that doesn't have any
attributes it doesn't have any ideas
it's open it's spacious it's loving it's
unified from that place from that place
without a name without a location
without identity without any of those
things from that place from that place
then is the Wrath against all Injustice
and the warrior for New World from that
place from that place it's obvious God
is playing a game with himself which is
you playing a game with yourself which
includes
the appearance of these satanic programs
that are anti- holism they're anti-
nature they're
anti-human they're Pro greed Pro
corruption pro- selfishness Pro ego and
all of those are to be destroyed with
the fiery Breath of God and all of these
blueprints for the New World Systems of
energy abundance housing abundance food
water abundance all those blueprints are
to be actualized again with God's
excitement for celebration and
prosperity for generations to come for a
beautiful unification and harmony with
nature